even in a cavy uniform the Norwegian  p.m. had difficulty staying incognito  driving taxi part time now you look just  like him an ad agency planned the Sun to  show stoltenberg can relate to voters he  and his passengers chatted about energy  policy education reform and executive  salaries I'm in luck I was planning to  write you a letter yesterday after  battles Stoltenberg shot behind the  wheel took place on a Friday after his  weekly meeting with the King are you  going to vote yes that's good it's  important stoltenberg champagne is  trying to attract more young voters but  when asked if he'd consider driving a  taxi full-time the prime minister said  both norway and the country's taxi  passengers would be better off if he  stuck with being Prime Minister